ici là c'est ici que la digue ACD
Richard Lozon revient à l'occasion à
Sainte-Marthe-sur-le-Lac
les souvenirs rejaillissent quand ils
revoit le quartier où il a élevé ses
enfants ça c'est la maison que je veux
voir mon père une maison qui la revendu
à perte il raconte son drame à son
ancienne voisine qu'il croise au passage
133000 pour
rebâtir une maison de deux étages
il estime avoir perdu 400000 dollars
cette détresse financière la forcée a
déménagé à l'extérieur de sa petite
ville il a dû se résigner à devenir
locataire mais j'ai travaillé toute ma
vie pour une maison
je me retrouve avec pour rien
c'est ridicule le soir du 27 avril 2019
l'impensable s'est produit la digue qui
retient le lac des Deux Montagnes ACD
2000 propriétés ont été inondées les
sinistrés reprochent aux autorités
d'avoir négligé un rapport qui alertait
des 2017 des faiblesses de la digue
aujourd'hui la reconstruction va bon
train aux abords de la nouvelle digue
qui s'élève à plus de 26 mètres
au-dessus du niveau de la mer on voit ça
le descendu donc pour lever il faut que
tu fasses le mur de pierre des champs
Nathalie n'en a toujours pas fini avec
les travaux après 4 ans de blocage
bureaucratique on va enlever la maison
refaire le solage parce que la maison
bougeait des fondations j'ai des
fissures partout à l'intérieur de la
maison tellement que ça a le travailler
j'ai des portes qui ferment plus les
dommages psychologiques demeurent les
plus douloureux depuis la catastrophe
elle vit avec des migraines et un
trouble du sommeil je suis fatigué parce
que c'est beaucoup beaucoup de démarches
c'est pas évident c'est pas évident
n'est pas accompagné il y a pas de
soutien
tout changer le voisinage Michel se
souvient de ses amis pris à la gorge qui
ont dû vendre leur terrain de nouveaux
habitants les ont remplacé mais son
cercle social s'était fruité j'ai perdu
énormément d'amis il faut figurer que 60
maisons qui ont été démolis ici je
critère pas les nouveaux venus mais les
gens qui sont ici ils ont pas vécu
ce qu'on a vécu nous autres
c'est dramatique
il y a des gens qui se sont divorcés
parce que d'abord
Richard fait partie de ceux qui ont
disparu du paysage mais il n'a pas dit
son dernier mot j'ai décidé de
parce que je voulais faire de quoi pas
juste pour moi le fait pour tout le
monde voilà
d'espoir son action collective a
finalement été autorisée par un juge un
pas de pluie pour obtenir une réparation
qui ne ramènera toutefois pas les
maisons perdues
Radio-Canada Sainte-Marthe sur le lac